hey welcome back to the monitor I'm
Peter Rubin senior editor wired and this
week I am just overjoyed that Tom Cruise
is back to do what he does best and that
is not to be Jack Reacher and that is
not to be in Rock of Ages that is to
save the world yes he is back in
Oblivion he actually comes back to earth
he's been living on this moon revolving
around Saturn he comes back to earth on
this maintenance mission and he meets
this band of human resistance and
everything just jumps off it is it's big
sci-fi and we've got Morgan Freeman
wearing steampunk goggles and you know
there's nothing wrong with that or
conversely maybe there's everything
wrong with that but I'm willing to
overlook it this is directed by joseph
kosinski who made tron legacy so if your
complaints about tron legacy was
everything as to indoorsy and computery
and there's too much daft punk now you
go outside and it's by m83 different
score same electronic music joseph
kosinski definitely has a palette that
he's working with and you can see his
aesthetic from tron at play here the
spaceships the fashions things like that
at any rate Tom Cruise he's in Oblivion
it's out this week let's talk about
video games now out this week for the
video game digital delivery service
steam on PCs and Macs is a game that was
available last year on the playstation
network called papo yo not only is this
one of the most fun video game titles to
say in recent memories it's also one of
the most surprising this game was
informed by the game creative directors
experience growing up with an alcoholic
father you will play a child in the game
whose best friend is a monster who was
kind of addicted to these poisonous
frogs and when he eats them he flies
into a murderous rage you can really
feel the tension and the struggle of
loving this flawed creature who may turn
on you at any moment but in their good
periods has nothing but love and
goodwill it's really moving if you like
your games with a little bit of
emotional heft papo eeo is a great game
in that broad category it's available on
Steam if you don't think you have steam
but you have a PC or a Mac and guess
what you do have steam it's a free
download popular yo is not free you're
going to have to pay for that but Papa
yo out on Steam this week give it a go
great emotionally set
fine puzzle game let's talk about music
so believe it or not it's been 20 years
since the wu-tang's first album and
while their members have kind of shined
and old and gone into obscurity and come
back the most consistent rapper from the
womb believe it or not has ended up bein
ghostface killah and he is out this week
with I think his three hundred and forty
ninth studio album this is called twelve
reasons to die and it was actually
composed by a young musician named
adrian young and recorded live with
adrian Young's band which means that it
is a ghost face album with a live score
if you think about it this makes a lot
of sense ghost as always love that kind
of lush soulful 70s feel in his
production and a lot of his best albums
like fish scale and pretty Tony kind of
had that sonic backdrop and twelve
reasons to die is no exception it's very
much a vivid concept album II kind of
journey in Grand ghostface killah style
but that is out this week ghostface
killah and adrian younge twelve reasons
to die give that a listen but that is it
for the monitor this week we'll be back
next week with more pop culture goodness
but until then inspirational catchphrase
here
you